before we go we have to end on some good  vibes with cardi b showing off her you  know her new house a stunning mansion  offset gifted her for her 29th birthday  after telling him she's always wanted to  invest in short-term rental home  properties and if this is 29 imagine  what he's going to get it for her 30. i  can't even  yeah i'm not sure how he's going to top  that uh taking instagram cardi gushed  about offset  getting her dad involved with the gift  writing in part  you and my dad are the most important  men in my life and it makes me so happy  that you guys are close and have your  own bond and relationship and the video  confirmed the property has six bedrooms  and seven and a half bathrooms oh and  has a beautiful wow view an infinity  pool and a lot more but what are the  toilets like that's right are they next  to each other  take care everyone take a look bye  [Laughter]  [Music]  you